so I want to make five promises to you
today
five pledges to deliver peace of mind
five foundations on which to build a
better future for our children and
grandchildren
first
we will halve inflation this year to
ease the cost of living and give people
Financial Security
second
we will grow the economy creating better
paid jobs and opportunity right across
the country
third
we will make sure our national debt is
falling so that we can secure the future
of Public Services
fourth
NHS waiting lists will fall and people
will get the care they need more quickly
fifth
we will pass new laws to stop small
boats making sure that if you come to
this country illegally you are detained
and swiftly removed
so
five promises
we will halve inflation grow the economy
reduce debt cut waiting lists and stop
the boats those are the people's
priorities they are your government's
priorities and we will either have
achieved them or not no tricks no
ambiguity
we're either delivering for you or we're
not